moi je ne veux plus qu'il y ait de gens
de Québécois qui soient obligés
d'attendre dehors en plein hiver pour
recevoir leurs services
le ministre des Transports Geneviève
Guilbault Hitler des solutions à partir
d'aujourd'hui on va en discuter tout de
suite avec Denis marcelet président
directeur général de la sac qui est là
bonjour monsieur Marcelin
bonjour
je sais pas si ça vous a appelé
directement mais en tout cas vous saviez
à quoi vous en tenir ce matin j'ai
encore vu des gens là à pointe clair on
a montré tout à l'heure à votre comptoir
c'est un mandataire c'est la C&A qui est
là et encore des gens qui attendent à
l'extérieur alors ils vont entendre
encore combien de temps on a une
vingtaine de minutes avant que les
portes ouvre
rassurez-vous on parle je parle de
crémonis quelques fois par jour alors on
est en constante
je suis très conscient de la situation
j'ai moi-même été dans 5 ou 6 points de
service là depuis vendredi dernier et
nous sommes un pied d'oeuvre pour
respecter les attentes et atteindre des
attentes de la ministre parce que je
suis entièrement d'accord avec ça ça a
pas de bon sens que des gens attendent à
l'extérieur alors on est en train de
trésorber à tout le moins tes files
d'attente ou à l'intérieur saint Jérôme
c'est déjà réglé Henri-Bourassa qui est
un grand centre à Montréal on est en
train il y a pas de place à l'intérieur
on est en train de prévoir quelque chose
cet après-midi ça va être les gens vont
être au chaud et
l'idée au delà des apprendre à
l'extérieur il faut travailler sur les
files d'attente comment on peut réserver
les files d'attente pour faire en sorte
que les citoyens arrivent pas à 7h30
passe la journée et se retourne chez eux
brado et après alors ce qu'on fait on
est initié de façon plus proactive
encore ce matin de ce matin à 7h30 il y
avait dans les points dans les points
chauds 5 personnes qui épaulaient le
personnel sur place pour faire en sorte
de gérer à deux campements les files
d'attente donc âgées de façon proactive
et demander à tous et chacun pour quelle
raison se trouve de malsaintes
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a une urgence
est-ce que ça peut être reporté est-ce
que le citoyen qui est là à 8h par
exemple est-ce qu'on peut donner
rendez-vous dans la journée pour qu'il
vienne à 4h ou à 4h30 ce qu'on veut
tenter de faire puis je dis on met
toutes les énergies puis en passant je
remercie l'ensemble de mes employés
parce que depuis deux semaines je sais
que c'est pas facile pour eux mais ce
qu'on tente de faire c'est que
d'éliminer au maximum les files
d'attente de pas faire des gens de leur
donner des rendez-vous pour qu'il
revienne en journée ou aux besoins
lorsque des urgences on va prolonger les
heures d'ouverture pour à ce moment-là
demander aux citoyens de revenir à telle
heure par exemple à 5h30 6h avec un
rendez-vous et là on voit traiter
le dossier du citoyen et même on a
ouvert deux ou succursales en fin de
semaine avec des rendez-vous on a traité
1000 clients samedi matin dans les
différents dates
pourquoi Monsieur marcelet vous avez
décidé de manger l'éléphant d'une seule
bouchée connaissez le dicton un éléphant
ça se mange bouché à la fois mais vous
avez ouvert la gueule très grand pour
manger tous les lapins on n'aurait pas
pu commencer par les a ou les baies ou
les
vous savez vous en ai dit pour 40 ans
récupérer
c'est pas c'est pas parce que on avait
beaucoup d'appétit c'est parce qu'on y
avait pas d'autres façons technologique
de le faire vous savez on a on a eu un
transférer on est parti de 10 milliards
de dossiers on le réduit à un milliard
de dossiers comprenant une faute de
photos parce qu'on fait les photos et de
faire cette migration là de l'ancien
système au nouveau système on ne pouvait
pas avoir la coïstance de deux de deux
plateformes parce que les on va
rassembler 300 applications qu'on avait
depuis les 40 dernières années c'était
tout un opération comprend que ça
n'était pas mal plus simple pour nous
vous aviez pas de cauchemars quand vous
avez vu les fils d'attente au bureau des
passeports les dépasser on venait pas à
bout de réserver le problème puis là
vous vous dites on va transférer 40 ans
de données de films de un puis de 0
comme ça dans des ordinateurs vous avez
dû perdre du soleil
alors rassurez-vous puis je suis très
sensible à ce qui se passe là il était
curateur avant il y a un an alors je
peux la sensibilité là je connais ça
ce qu'on veut là c'est que les citoyens
puissent
ouvrir leur compte client à sa clique il
y a 50% des citoyens se présentent des
centres de services où on se parle
monsieur maçon et qui aurait pu faire
cette transaction là par le web s'ils
étaient clients et s'ils étaient
adapte de fonctions
de confusion bon comme on est la
première transformation numériquement de
façon importante il y a eu le centre
d'authentification gouvernementale donc
c'est de passage obligé pour
s'authentifier qui demande quatre pièces
et ça ça freiné certaines personnes
pour pas dire n'importe quoi il y a eu
330 000 clients qui ont été servis
depuis les 10 derniers jours puis parmi
ces 330 000 là il y a 103.000 clients
qui ont fait la transaction à distance
par le biais de sa clique alors
je suis heureux d'avoir l'occasion de
dire à vous téléspectateurs aujourd'hui
allez-y sur sa clique et il va avoir des
mesures d'atténuation dès la semaine
prochaine pour pouvoir authentifier les
personnes sur place dans les centres de
service avec deux cartes évidemment le
permis de conduire et leur carte
d'assurance maladie
parce que j'avais poursu ma nouvelle
place vous savez celle qui s'est
détériorée ou encore qui sont dit moi je
veux renouveler mon permis de conduire
monsieur l'agent c'est pas possible il y
a ces gens-là qui ont eu des
contraventions est-ce que est-ce que ça
c'est normal ou est-ce que des recours
pour qu'il y ait pas payer les
contraventions s'ils sont en attente
d'une réponse de votre bureau
écoutez je vous dirai pas que c'est
normal c'est tout à fait normal qu'on
s'en excuse
entre la période service partielle du 26
janvier au 20 février il y a des gens
qui ont payé leur renouvellement de
permis tout ça mais comme on ne pouvait
pas l'inscrire dans la nouvelle
plateforme mais c'est aussi là sont en
train de rattrapage est en train d'être
manuellement
est inscrite dans le la nouvelle
plateforme et donc lorsque les policiers
consultaient leur registre ils voyaient
que la personne sont permis par exemple
était expirés mais il voyait pas le
paiement alors on ne corrigé donner un
indication sur une belle plateforme puis
s'il y a des gens qui nous écoutent qui
ont eu des contremars de ça d'abord on
s'en excuse je pense que il y a personne
qui soit de ça puis nous on va prendre
la charge
parce que c'est pas aux citoyens de
payer ce transfert-là évidemment ça fait
partie du transfert je vous parle
toujours des 1 milliards de données
c'est c'est pas même voilà on est les
travailler sur un des employés sont en
train d'apprivoiser le nouveau système
mon on est quand même au même on se
parle monsieur Masson un rendement de
70% de ce qu'on faisait avant la
migration ça veut dire que on rend
service au niveau de 70 % au client fait
que il reste 30 % pour retourner à
un rendement normal c'est que je pense
que il y a eu une augmentation tous les
jours là puis les employés sont là pour
servir
pour être capable de donner le même
service je m'excuse je parle beaucoup
mais j'ai plein de choses à vous dire
d'abord au fur et à mesure que la
situation évoluera monsieur Marcelin bon
courage et bonne chance merci beaucoup
d'avoir été disponible ce matin pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI